BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
BILL LUAN: Hello and
welcome to another
episode GDL-IL, GDL Israel.
Today we are going to speak
about HTML5, some cool new
things that we see today.
And of course, we're going to
deep dive into web workers and
why this HTML5 API lets you
use multi-thread in the
browsers is very great way
to actually improve your
performance and make sure that
your web apps and websites are
working better and utilized
quad-core, 8-core, or any
other number of cores that the
devices that your browsers is
running on.
So without further ado, let's
jump and see some code.
Let me share my screen
with you.
And we are hopefully if
I'm jumping-- yeah.
So for the ones that don't know,
let me just open it and
make it a bit bigger
but on this spot.
So it will be here,
right here.
Let's make it bigger.
So at ido-green.appspot.com, you
could see all the sources
and everything that we
will cover today.
And as you saw probably, the
first screen that I shared
with you was a post that I wrote
actually almost now a
year ago about big data
and web workers.
And the promise of the big thing
there is that today in
modern browsers--
and more and more browsers are
actually implementing this
important HTML5 feature--
allowing us to work
with big data.
And when I'm saying big data,
it's with half a smile because
it's not teras, but still few
megs that up to now, when we
wanted to move them, we
postMessage to the window
object or to the
worker object.
It was quite hard.
Luckily, today with HTML5, we
could use transferable object
and do that very,
very quickly.
This is a good link to start
with, which is the spec of
transferable object.
And basically, from a macro
level what we have here is
that just a moving and
not a copy operation.
So I'm going to be moving a
pointer, and we're getting a
boost in our performances.
In this specific case, our
specific example, you can see
that basically what we have
here is a way to use
transferable object or not to
use them, and then we're just
seeing what huge difference it's
bringing in terms of the
amount of seconds that it will
cause our worker to get a
data, crunch it, and
return it back.
This is the example page.
And as you can see here
on ido-green.appspo
t.com/HTML5webcom, this is
part of a presentation.
And basically when we're running
the test, you can see
here that it's taking it two
milliseconds on average, maybe
three, four.
Let me make it a bit bigger so
it will be easier to see.
Now if you will take the exact
URL here and basically copy to
an older browsers that are not
supporting transferable
objects, you'll see a number
here that is at
least 50 times higher.
In most of the cases that I've
checked, it was around 150,
160 milliseconds.
So it's quite nice to see that
today we have a very efficient
way to work with web workers
because, of course, the
bottleneck wasn't in the CPU
or the work that the worker
itself is doing for us but more
in the way that we are
transmitting big data--
again with a half a smile--
to the worker and back
to our web app.
Here is another link.
Basically I wrote
the book with O'
Reilly about web workers.
But all the examples of the book
are, off course, free for
use on GitHub.
And you could see it here and
basically get and [INAUDIBLE]
all the different examples.
The ones that we will focus
today are just two quite nice
examples that I wanted
to share with you.
So let's go here and
try now again to
share the example page.
It's right here.
The reason I just switch windows
is because I wish to
show you this example
in Chrome Canary.
For the web developers here
that aren't using Chrome
Canary when they are developing,
I highly advise
you to try it.
It's a great way to stay up to
date with all the new features
that you have in Chrome and
that you will see in the
stable version after six
weeks, more or less.
Because as you all know, Chrome
is out there every six
weeks with new features and
improvements to its speed,
security, and simplicity
of course.
And here in Chrome Canary, we
have several things that are
new but basically harnessing
us with better ability to
debug web workers.
As you could see here--
let me just load this
page from the start--
what we have here is a web
worker that we would use in
order to calculate pi.
And as you could see here, I
could choose the amount of
cycles that I wish to do and
then start the worker.
And, I hope that you could all
see now that what I have here
is basically a [INAUDIBLE]
Chrome DevTools.
Yeah, I see that you don't see
because you see the main page.
Let me again share with
you the right window,
and let's see here.
Yeah, Chrome DevTools.
So the nice thing here is what
you see here is basically the
Chrome DevTools that you all
know and, I hope, love.
But here, the main difference is
that as you could see now,
we are in the example pi.js,
which is our worker.
And what I did is that I just
checked one check box to make
sure that on the start of
everything, our web worker's
DevTool window will
be open for us.
And then we'll be able to go
step-by-step and just use the
debugger as we like.
As you can see here, I have
an event listener.
And I'm getting two messages--
the Start and the
Stop buttons.
So in this case, since you are
aware that I clicked on the
Start button, if we just release
it, you see that I'm
holding now on the postMessage
of the Start case.
And now we could go case-by-case
and just have our
calculation.
You could see here that I have
the right number with me.
And now, basically, I just need
to communicate it back to
the parent, which is the
index.html5 app.
I just release it, and
now let's switch
again to the main window.
Here it is.
And as you could see
here nicely--
let me make it a bit bigger.
Not this one, but
rather this one.
So I got the messages as you
could see here in the
DevTools, and we got the amount
of cycles that we are
going to run.
And then we got our
answer back.
And as you could all see, we
have here the right answer.
Maybe we should step one or two
steps back and just let me
share with you--
let's close this one--
when we're talking about web
workers, what are the most
basic, fundamental components
that we're working with and we
want to see in a web worker?
So let me here just go--
yeah.
So let's do it again, and we'll
just load a new screen
that I'll share with you.
And we'll see what are the most
basic components of web
workers and how we could
work with them.
[INAUDIBLE].
IDO GREEN: If people
are joining,
please just put on mute.
It will be great.
[INAUDIBLE].
IDO GREEN: OK.
So, let's take [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE].
IDO GREEN: Yes.
So what we have basically--
[INAUDIBLE]
let me take and show you
this quick example.
I hope you all see my window.
Yeah, it's going to
be quite quick.
We'll reach to the part
that we want to show.
Yeah.
So basically, when we are
talking about web workers, we
have three elements that we
want to take and note.
First is in our one-page app, in
our mobile web app, in our
web app, we want to be able to
get out of the realm of the
single thread that our
JavaScript engine allow us to
do and just start a new thread
on the side, crunch some
number there.
It could be 3D metrics
calculation.
It could be route calculation
on maps.
It could be anything that right
now you're doing with
hacks of setTimeout or things
like that and you just want to
purely do it off the main
thread, so it will not
interfere with the DOM, with
the window that you are
showing the user.
So the user won't see any
sluggishness, and everything
will work really
nice and fast.
So what you need to do in your
index HTML5 is just call your
work with this constructor.
And basically you're just
pointing to a JavaScript file
that contain all the
logic that the
worker itself will run.
After that, the only two other
things is to create the
communication channel
with the worker.
So one, we'll just create a new
event listener and just
hook it, so we'll be able to
send some commands, some data,
to the worker and, of course,
get back from the worker
information.
In this example, I'm
just sending at the
beginning some settings--
so some initial agent settings,
and that's it.
In the worker itself, what we
need to do is, of course, aid
the event listener, so we'll
have the postmaster channel
with our master or parent
if you will.
Then, of course, have a main
function of doing some work.
And here, I just choose to
put as an example JSONP.
So it's quite powerful.
The specification in a worker
doesn't allow you to do
everything that you could do
today in the window of the
main DOM object.
But it's good enough, and
you could do quite a lot
of things with it.
One of them is just leveraging
the power of JSONP and just
import scripts from the
outside world and just
register a callback to them
to handle the work.
And in our case, we just choose
this amazing generic
name, handleWork.
And here we'll just do the work
when we're getting the
results from the callback and,
in this case, post the message
back to the parent.
So here it will get it again,
and it will do the right
things with it--
probably communicate it back
to the user with some DOM
manipulation that reflect
the calculation that
we did in our worker.
Few things that are quite nice
to note and are quite
important, actually--
let me first just remove this
image that with my big screen
doesn't for work well here.
And now, when we removed it, we
could focus better on what
we're doing here.
So first and foremost, you
want to use Modernizr.
Modernizr is a great framework
that basically allow you to
make sure that you have web
worker in the browser.
How you do that?
After you are basically import
the Modernizr library, you
just set up a if statement.
And with this if statement,
everything that you do after
that-- if it's true, of course,
letting you know that
you do have web workers in
the specific browsers.
How Modernizr look like?
Well, you can find it on GitHub,
and you could check
lot of great things that Paul
Irish, Bruce [INAUDIBLE]
and other great contributors
are saying about it.
The other big and major thing
about it is shared workers.
Shared workers is basically
a web worker that could be
shared between several
windows or tabs.
So you can think of it as one
point of communication with
your local database, your
local index DB.
Or maybe if you have a database
in the cloud or some
other logic that you want one
place to communicate with,
that's the right location
to put it.
And the great things about it
is that, if you'll see when
I'm opening the Chrome DevTools,
very easily I could
go and make sure that I will
be able to debug workers.
And how?
With that.
On Source tab--
as you saw what I did.
I just went to the
Source tab--
down here, we have workers.
So like we're putting any other
break points, we could
just mark this check box,
Impose on Start.
And then, as I said, shared
workers will be inspected the
Task Manager, but regular
workers like the one I showed
will be just stopped here.
And that's basically the example
that we start our GDL
today with.
What else we could
say about it?
Yeah, of course, we
have a link here
to the worker itself.
And when I clicked on it,
basically I opened another
window that let me debug it.
And let's close this one.
And of course, you could have
a link here with all the
examples that we are going on,
and I showed you it's all on
GitHub now for free,
of course.
So I think that's it.
I see that we have
a few questions.
If someone would like to
ask a question, this
is the right time.
Great.
So if there are no more
questions, let's see if we
have some more things that
I wanted to share today.
Let me share the screen
one more time please.
Let's see here.
Yeah, this is the right one.
And this is the example of
the transferable object.
This is the location of the
web workers examples.
Let me make it a bit bigger.
And the easiest way
to do it is just--
yeah.
And of course you could see and
read more thoroughly what
we covered today on my blog,
greenido.wordpress.com.
Let me put it just here
so you'll all see it.
It's right here.
So if you'll search web workers
on this blog, you're
probably going to see all the
different things that you
could do with web workers.
And until next time,
be strong and safe.
And next week, we are going
to have here an AngularJS
specialist, [INAUDIBLE]
that will share with us
some of his thoughts.
So you are most welcome to join
us in our next GDL-IL.
It will be on next week
at 2:00 Israel time.
And until then, see you later.
Bye-bye, guys.